that's even do you like having a picture
taken uh no really I funny enough on the
red carpet thing reminds me um the first
time we we went to the Golden Globes Wow
no want to know but we we went on was
for the office and it was the British
and we never been to anything as
glamorous as it or as exciting as now
we've got to do the red carpet and all
these super famous people were there
maybe Salazar I don't know and and then
that we want miraculously and everyone
had told us you will not win there's no
way just go and have the free booze in
the food and enjoys up so we're there
and they call our names and it was crazy
and if you look at the camera footage
now if you look at it they were on the
table so far away from the stage because
no waiters win and so the cameras kind
of looking for us CS and then eventually
so Ricky's little face pops up and then
I saw a car like a giant and we sort of
fight our way to the stage and the
announcer has no idea who we are so he's
just saying because Ricky's last name is
french-canadian the announcer says
coming to the stage Ricky Gervais and
Stephen Mitchell
and anyway so they take our picture of
all these photos taken and then everyone
says you're gonna be in the paper Monday
in the British paper I was back sighs
first time I never been in the paper
before and I was super psyched as we say
in America and and so we got a photo and
and and are you gonna well we got the
picture well see if you can spot the the
reason why I was a little bit
disappointed by my first appearance in a
national paper okay this is it
so it's so rude look how happy I am
but fan down pan down they had room for
these people the photographer's only got
seconds he's like what do they want to
say think they'll see these guys do
these ball
this I don't believe this Fleetwood
we're breastfeeding is always welcome
what happened in Fleetwood ographers
miss the moment when Kanye broke a smile
no no they did not
that did not happen let's say there's a
follow-up